[Music]
but why do they land on
yeah that's a good question do you know
the answer yeah this i think is musca
domestica or the common house fly which
if i had the chance to study insects
again take a couple years out and study
insects again i would probably zone in
on the common house fly and you do see
the common house uh the common house fly
on
feces i'm gonna call it from now on
uh-huh uh both human and uh other
animals as well as other flies and the
reason for that is because they lay
their eggs in the feces and then the
maggots will eat
the feces because there's a huge amount
of nutrients in
poo so hold on then yeah so is it only
female flies that land on feces then
generally yeah although i would probably
put an argument forward to say that male
flies are also interested in the social
aspect of a huge amount of female flies
flying around pooh so if you were to
take a bag and capture all the flies i'd
say probably 85 to 90 of them will be
female but some of them will be male
because they're looking to mate they're
hanging around there because they know
that a lot of a lot of women
are hanging around covered
but
if we didn't have flies as an example of
a very important insect we would have a
massive amount of
human and animal waste sitting around
and degrading much slower than it would
do if you didn't have these animals
around so with you know someone's not
picked up after their dog within a few
days
less than a week that's probably
disappeared because of all the animals
using it for fuel if we didn't have
those animals you know not only would it
be disgusting but probably more chance
of disease and pestilence
[Music]
harmonize with me and hold me back all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your oyster baby you're my pearl